merci d'être avec nous que c'est encore
bon pour cette première demi-heure
sénateur les républicains du
Val-de-Marne vous préciser la commission
des affaires étrangères de la défense et
des forces armées du Sénat on va
évidemment revenir sur vos nombreux
déplacements mais d'abord un mot vous
l'avez vu sur ce qui s'est passé hier en
séance et ce grave incident interruption
des questions d'actualité après les
propos d'un député du rassemblement
national Grégoire de Fournas qu'il
retourne en Afrique c'est ce qu'il a dit
c'est ce que dit le compte-rendu de la
séance cette nuit alors qu'un député de
la France insoumise posait la question
sur les bateaux de migrants Méditerranée
alors le député qui parlait du bateau le
député de la France insoumise ses senti
visé quel regard vous portez sur cette
séquence c'est une séquence lamentable
c'est une séquence lamentable car elle
ne sert pas
le rôle que le Parlement doit jouer dans
ce pays singulièrement dans les temps
que nous connaissons et nous assistons à
une multiplication à l'Assemblée
nationale
singulièrement aux deux extrêmes de ce
genre d'incident qui met en cause
vis-à-vis de l'opinion publique le
sérieux des débats parlementaires moi
j'invite nos collègues députés et
singulièrement ceux des deux extrêmes
se passent au Sénat il y a des débats il
y a des controvers s'il y a des
difficultés il n'y a jamais de
provocation notamment raciste
moi je vais pas entrer dans le débat de
savoir si l'interjection était
singulière ou pluriel je dis simplement
que nous avons une responsabilité c'est
d'offrir au pays une image de sérieux de
responsabilité et si ça l'assemblée
mentarisme alors là franchement on
nourrit tout à fait ce courant je pense
que c'est très des dégradants et je suis
très heureux si j'ai au Sénat car mes
collègues députés que je connais et qui
notamment dans le groupe Lerne sont
désemparés face à ce climat
trouve évidemment que le débat n'est pas
à la hauteur de ce qui doit être
vous étiez en Corée on va parler de vos
déplacements on parle du Kurdistan dans
quelques instants mais vous étiez en
Corée ces derniers jours vous êtes
revenus vous venez tout juste de revenir
et depuis quelques jours on observe un
brutal regain de tension entre les deux
Corée la Corée du Nord à lancer
plusieurs missiles qui se sont qui ont
été tout près des autres territoriales
de Corée du Sud pardon la Corée du Sud
qui a répondu est-ce que vous craignez
un nombre rasement il y a manifestement
un très grave moment de tension qui est
d'abord assez habituel du fait de la
Corée du Nord quand même qui multiplie
les tirs domicile je rappelle que cette
fois-ci un des missiles qui ont été
tirés au moment où je quittais la Corée
un des missiles est tombé dans les eaux
territoriales quand même de la Corée du
Sud donc et j'ai souhaité aller à panung
John c'est-à-dire à la frontière dans un
endroit où la tension est extrême on
voit de toutes parts que le moins
d'incident peut dégénérer c'est un des
points les plus chauds du monde je crois
que c'était important qu'au de la
diplomatie parlementaire la France qui
parle beaucoup de sa présence dans le
monde ado Pacifique soit présente auprès
d'un pays comme la Corée du Sud qui est
un de nos alliés les plus sûrs qui
pratiquent quand même dans une région du
monde où c'est assez rare les valeurs de
la démocratie qui respectent la liberté
et donc j'ai aussi souhaité que cette
partie du de se déplacement de cette
mission puisse avoir un temps mémorielle
en allant à pouza ne m'incliner devant
le monument des du bataillon français de
l'ONU nous avons perdu quand même 247
hommes dans cette affaire ou plus de
3000 des notes étaient partis dans les
années 50-53 et il y a 43 soldats qui
sont enterrés là-bas moi je suis très
attentif à ça ceux qui sont morts en
Afghanistan ceux qui sont morts au Mali
ceux qui sont morts en Corée et bien il
faut qu'on garde leurs souvenirs et
quand on est de passage dans ces pays je
mets toujours un point d'honneur à les
machiner pour qu'on ne les oublie pas
on va parler d'un autre de vos
déplacements c'était il y a plusieurs
jours vous êtes allés au Kurdistan
irakien je ne vais que dans les endroits
où ça va bien oui
de ce déplacement et des enjeux pour la
France dans cette région notre
journaliste Jonathan du prix à vous a
suivi son documentaire sera diffusé
demain à 18h il nous rejoint pour en
parler
[Musique]
bonjour Jonathan merci d'être là et on
disait vous avez donc suivi Christian
Cambon Kurdistan irakien votre reportage
intitulé Kurdistan un territoire à
l'épreuve 26 minutes ce sera diffusé
demain à 18h vous avez donc suivi cette
mission de Christian Cambon et
finalement Jonathan on connaît assez peu
cette région oui c'est vrai on sait pas
très bien ce que c'est le Kurdistan
irakien on en a entendu parler mais en
fait bah c'est déjà 5000 km de Paris
c'est un territoire en plein cœur du
Moyen-Orient ce n'est pas un état même
si ça fonctionne presque pareil avec son
économie son armée en fait c'est une
région qui est rattachée à l'Irak une
région qui a son autonomie depuis 2005
qui compte environ 5 millions
d'habitants pour la majorité c'est des
musulmans sunnites qui ont leur identité
propre très marquée une histoire c'est
un peuple des langues particulières
aussi donc ça ça en fait un territoire
atypique atypique et stratégique pour la
France oui absolument et ça fait même 30
ans d'ailleurs que la France et le
Kurdistan sont très très liés la France
a par exemple pris des positions très
fortes à la fin des années à la fin des
années 80 pour la cause kurde face aux
persécutions de Saddam Hussein dans la
région et puis aussi on peut on peut se
dire qu'en France il y a une très grande
diaspora kurde 300.000 cures d'en France
là s'ajoute aussi sur le plan
géopolitique une région que nous en tout
cas en France on voit comme une région
clé un verrou stratégique sécurité entre
la Syrie la Turquie et l'Iran à l'Est
bref en tout cas les liens France
Kurdistan sont ténus et c'est pour ça
que les liens diplomatiques le sont tout
autant et donc Christian Campbon vous
nous le dites vous avez fait de la
diplomatie parlementaire en tout cas
dans le reportage je vous l'expliquais
très bien on va regarder
Christian Cambon président de la
commission des affaires étrangères de la
défense et des forces armées du Sénat de
la République française le sénateur
coiffé de sa casquette de diplomate
vient porter la voix de la chambre haute
auprès des autorités Kurdes quand on est
président de la commission des affaires
étrangères et de la défense on est un
peu diplomate sur les bords c'est vrai
que on a tout de même le sentiment
au-delà de sa propre personne de
représenter la France et en tous les cas
le Parlement français
Christian Cambon ne vient pas ici en
francs-tireurs au Kurdistan sa voix est
alignée sur celle du Quai d'Orsay
la diplomatie parlementaire ce n'est pas
une diplomatie indépendante c'est celle
que conduit le gouvernement nos
ambassadeurs nos consultes généraux et
donc les parlementaires sont alors cotés
pour les aider dans cette mission et je
crois que c'est un c'est un rôle
important
[Musique]
un rôle important sur un territoire jugé
stratégique pour la France le Kurdistan
est une région autonome de l'Irak depuis
2005 et partage ses frontières avec la
Syrie la Turquie et l'Iran
ce territoire épargné par l'invasion
américaine de 2003 fait figure de pôles
de stabilité au milieu d'une zone
troublée aux yeux de la France le
Kurdistan est un poste d'observation
privilégié sur le Moyen-Orient
[Musique]
quand vous êtes en déplacement comme ça
vous êtes un peu diplomate sur les bords
c'est ce que vous dites vous représentez
la France comment vous travaillez avec
le quai d'or c'est quel est le rôle de
cette diplomatie parlementaire alors
d'abord ce sont des voyages qui se
préparent longtemps à l'avance et qui
sont négociées avec nos ambassades et
les ambassades de ces pays présentent à
Paris et le rôle si vous voulez la
feuille de route que j'ai reçu du
président du Sénat Gérard Larcher c'est
de parler à tout le monde donc c'est pas
toujours facile croyez bien mais
important c'est effectivement que la
France tienne son rang ils tiennent son
rôle parce que trop souvent on se limite
à faire des déclarations et il faut que
quelque part on aille relayé l'action du
gouvernement moi j'ai été déjà à deux
reprises au Kurdistan dont une fois avec
le président de la République 24 heures
et j'avais été une autre fois avec
Jean-Yves Le Drian et on voit bien que
il y a dans ce dans ce pays compte tenu
de l'attitude que nous avons eu très
courageuse vis-à-vis du Kurdistan au
moment de daesh on se on a déjà un peu
oublié tout ça mais c'est un ça a été un
de nos alliés les plus solides face à
daesh et donc il faut pas les laisser
tomber et donc pour ça il faut avoir le
courage d'y aller de les soutenir notre
présence ma personne n'a aucune espèce
d'importance et l'institution qui est
importante qui est utile et donc là
l'idée c'est de comprendre d'abord
quelle est la situation elle est
compliquée qu'à comme on l'a bien
entendu il y a des difficultés entre
cette région du Kurdistan et l'État
irakien lui-même le graphe difficulté
mais il y a aussi les attentes vis-à-vis
de la France il nous a été demandé et ça
va être mon devoir de retransmettre ce
souhait il nous a été demandé il est
demandé à la France que l'on les aide à
se défendre quand nous y étions
puisqu'il y a des manifestations en Iran
vous savez l'Iran dès qu'il y a des
problèmes en Iran il considèrent que
c'est les pays voisins qui sont qui en
sont la cause et donc ils vont barbe et
donc on a lorsque nous étions il y avait
des bombardements qui venaient de la
part de milice chie divers et variés et
de l'Iran tout à côté donc il faut que
ces gens se défendent et c'était mon
rôle de bien identifier quels étaient
les besoins et en tant que président de
la Commission de façon générale et de la
défense c'est notre action à côté de nos
ambassadeurs et d'un consul général ou
demeurant extraordinaire
d'apporter notre soutien d'avoir des
entretiens officiels et de pouvoir
montrer que nous sommes là est-ce qu'il
faut peut-être dire aussi c'est que la
France par rapport à d'autres
diplomaties occidentales
une influence particulière au Kurdistan
absolument on a été parmi les premiers à
ouvrir un consulat général c'était du
temps de François Hollande ça a été très
bien apprécié il y a des institutions
culturelles et si vous voulez comme
c'est très loin on a l'impression de
voir tout ça dans un halo mais ce sont
des civilisations ce sont des religions
qui sont très différentes moi j'ai tenu
par exemple à aller à ce haut lieu de
culte des yésidiques on va en parler on
va voir un extrait mais juste parce que
vous dites que
de la France pour se défendre mais la
France elle a aussi besoin du Kurdistan
c'est aussi un administratif absolument
une bonne part du renseignement que nous
obtenons dans cette région du monde nous
vient du Kurdistan avec lequel nous
avons une coopération très étroite et
on sait aussi que
nombre d'attentats ont été fomentés dans
cette région du monde de tout le monde
sait que c'est taraka que c'est préparé
l'attentat du Bataclan donc il est
important qu'on soit aussi une région
très stratégique dans la lutte contre
l'État islamique sur la France
absolument c'est très important on va
justement parler des Yézidi hein puisque
dans le reportage vous montrer à quel
point ce territoire a été traumatisé je
n'en attend par la guerre contre daesh
avec encore des conséquences bien
visibles à digérer oui c'est ce qu'on
disait à l'instant on a tendance un peu
à oublier mais en fait quand Mossoul
tombe en 2016 en fait après les
djihadistes avancent quand même très
très vite vers
Erbil la capitale du Kurdistan irakien
et en fait ils sont stoppés à 30 km on
va dire à peu près une heure de une
heure la route de derbil donc il y a
aussi un tout un flot à ce moment-là de
déplacer à la fois syrien mais beaucoup
d'Irakiens surtout on estime aujourd'hui
depuis 2014 qui a un million 3 de
déplacés qui ont qui sont arrivés sur le
territoire que Kurd ce qui est énorme en
proportion de sa population je disais 5
millions d'habitants donc vous imaginez
ce que ça représente et je me suis rendu
notamment dans un camp où il y a
toujours des déplacés irakiens c'est un
camp maintenant il reste 5000 déplacés
et mais il y en a eu jusqu'à 70 000 à
l'époque la plus critique mais c'est
quand même des gens qui sont dans des
situations de blocage total à la fois
parce que ils ont plus de ressources ils
ont plus de d'habitation Mossoul est en
train de se reconstruire mais beaucoup
ont perdu leur maison donc ils ont plus
de travail il y a plus de il y a plus de
perspective et il y en a aussi pour des
raisons sécurité l'Irak refuse de
laisser partir en fait des camps
certains de ces déplacés qui ont des
liens avec l'État islamique qui soit
membre de d'anciens voilà d'anciens
combattants de DAEs etc donc il y a cet
empreinte quand même de daesh qui est
encore très très prégnante sur le
territoire kurde et on le disait il y a
aussi des cicatrices encore béantes
notamment sur certains certaines
communautés religieuses qui ont été
littéralement persécutés massacrés comme
les yésidis qui ont subi un génocide
l'ONU et Christian comment vous êtes
allés donc dans ce lieu dans le lieu
saint des à la lèche et on va regarder
un extrait
[Musique]
passage obligé pour le sénateur rayonner
autour du tombeau de l'un des principaux
références spirituels de la communauté
[Musique]
autre rite auquel le parlementaire doit
se plier le lancer de linge si le tissu
reste accroché au rocher cela signifie
que son vœu sera exaucé je me suis
jamais arrivé je me rassure
[Applaudissements]
toujours avoir un sénateur avec soi
c'est
croyances les yésidis les ont payé au
prix de leur vie dès 2014 des milliers
d'entre eux sont capturés par daesh puis
persécutés selon les ONG 5000 hommes
auraient été tués quant aux jeunes
filles et aux femmes 7000 d'entre elles
auraient été vendues et réduite à l'état
d'esclaves sexuel l'ONU a qualifié ses
atrocités de génocide
pas de les faire revenir hors à 5000 km
de leur territoire mais la France doit
aider à capturer ce la même qui ont mis
ces femmes en esclavage essayer de tout
faire par les moyens diplomatiques les
moyens militaires s'il le faut pas faut
avoir le courage de ces mots et faire en
sorte de manifester une solidarité et je
pense que Jonathan était témoin
le fait d'y avoir été mais c'est
toujours la même chose le fait d'être
présent c'est pas de la balade
sincèrement vous savez c'est c'est quand
même des voyages qui sont très
difficiles très fatigants mais le fait
d'avoir pu témoigner de notre solidarité
ils étaient absolument stupéfaits de
voir que un parlementaire français
venait les encourager alors moi j'ai pas
évidemment de moyens j'ai pas de crédit
pour acheter c'est malheureuses mais
déjà leur dire on sait ce qui se passe
et on va tourner à côté de tout faire et
Jonathan marge de la visite diplomatique
de Christian comment vous êtes allés à
la rencontre de personnalité de la
société civile on voit une région aux
prises à des problèmes internes oui tout
à fait je suis allé après dans d'autres
parties du territoire vous voyez dans
cette carte je suis allé plutôt à l'est
aussi vers la frontière avec l'Iran dans
la deuxième ville du Kurdistan qui
s'appelle souleymani et là j'ai
rencontré des opposants en fait il y a
deux parties au Kurdistan qui se
partagent l'influence sur le territoire
l'influence politique et ses opposants
et ben il raconte voilà de grandes
difficultés en tout cas à exercer leur
liberté d'expression il parle parfois
d'arrestation arbitraire et ils disent
même être surveillés quotidiennement que
leur téléphone sont écoutés enfin il y a
beaucoup de voilà de de problèmes à ce
sujet et ils peinent en fait simplement
à pouvoir faire usage de leur liberté
d'expression sacrétion pour moi aussi
c'est une question que vous avez pu
soulever notamment avec ou quand vous
êtes allés au Parlement du Kurdistan à
raconter nous ce que ce que vous avez
fait effectivement
c'est un souci que moi je porte en
permanence dans ces pays où la
démocratie n'est pas exactement
pratiquée selon les critères auxquels
nous sommes habitués alors il faut pas
non plus jeter bébé avec l'eau du bain
et il faut voir les progrès qu'on peut
être fait mais systématiquement dénoncer
les abus et moi lorsque j'ai pu
rencontrer la nouvelle présidente de
l'Assemblée nationale je lui ai dit
clairement que puisque très
courageusement cette femme a pris
justement le parti de défendre la presse
dans un pays où il y a beaucoup de
contraintes mais beaucoup de choses qui
ne vont pas faut dire les choses telles
qu'elles sont et donc j'ai rappelé
qu'elle était la position de la de la
France et c'est là aussi ou si vous
voulez notre rôle de dire on vous aide
mais aussi aidez vous-même et notamment
sur le plan des libertés on sait que ce
sont des régions qui ont connu des
régimes extrêmement répressifs et donc
ces pays c'est en l'occurrence une
région mais ces pays qui font des
efforts il faut à la fois pointer du
doigt là où ça ne va pas et puis aussi
les aider leur proposer des coopérations
moi j'ai proposé à la présidente de
l'Assemblée qui fait c'était fort et que
j'ai au nom du Président Larcher je l'ai
invité à venir à Paris pour qu'elle
porte son témoignage et je pense qu'il
faut qu'on les aide le Parlement peut
organiser une justement et leur dire que
la presse doit être libre
indiscutablement et dans ce sport très
robot aussi qu'on essaie de dresser de
ce territoire il y a aussi voilà des
difficultés d'ordre économique c'est un
territoire qui a beaucoup de richesses
pétrolières notamment mais il y a des
tensions très fortes avec Bagdad qui est
la tutelle de du Kurdistan donc pour
savoir en fait comment on exporte le
pétrole à qui vont les retomber donc ça
c'est des questions très compliquées au
Kurdistan il y a aussi des inégalités
très importantes entre ceux qui vivent
aussi du pétrole de la manne de
l'immobilier aussi qui est florissante
le salaire moyen c'est environ 180
dollars par mois et il y a des débouchés
très compliqués pour environ 10 000
diplômés par an pour la jeunesse en fait
du Kurdistan qui sait pas très bien ce
qu'elle va faire de son avenir une fois
qu'elle sort de l'université et donc je
me suis rendu à Rania qui a une ville
aussi et là encore très proche de l'Iran
ou on a rencontré voilà beaucoup de gens
qui étaient dans une impasse dans cet
impact économique et des familles aussi
qui témoigne de proches qui ont tout
simplement quitté le Kurdistan parce que
il y a beaucoup de jeunes maintenant qui
migrent et on va regarder cet extrait
à la frontière avec l'Iran la ville de
Rania a connu ces dernières années
plusieurs vagues de départ pour le Vieux
Continent des histoires souvent
tragiques que l'on entend dans les
salons de thé du centre-ville
bahez pleure aujourd'hui la disparition
de son frère
[Musique]
c'est la dernière photo que j'ai de lui
celle-ci a été prise ici au marché de
Rania
là on voit son passeport et sa carte
d'identité
il ne me reste que ces quelques photos
barrez avait 32 ans il est mort sur la
route des migrants à la frontière entre
la Turquie et la Bulgarie
le jeune homme avait un bon diplôme en
poche mais plus aucun espoir de
s'épanouir au Kurdistan
[Musique]
comme n'importe quel jeune du Kurdistan
il aurait pu avoir un bon boulot mais il
a fini coiffeur même s'il était doué il
était reconnu pour ce qu'il faisait à
Rania mais il n'aurait pas eu d'autres
opportunité
et malheureusement entre stagner ici et
finir au chômage il a préféré tenter sa
chance en Europe
c'est un extrait qui est fort ça a dû
reportage de Jonathan là aussi qu'est-ce
qu'on peut faire
c'est le drame permanent des réfugiés
les réfugiés s'en vont parce que les
conditions économiques d'éducation ou de
santé ne sont pas encore à la hauteur
moi personnellement je suis assez
optimiste sur ce qui va devenir du
Kurdistan parce que le Kurdistan comme
ça a été dit à des richesses il faut
simplement qu'elle soit mieux réparties
maintenant ce qui concerne les réfugiés
il tombe tous dans les mains de mafia de
passeur d'exploitants de d'esclavagistes
et donc certains n'en reviennent pas
c'est le cas qui est que que Jonathan a
rencontré moi j'étais déjà parti mais je
pense que ce reportage est important
sous cet angle et donc il faut montrer
la réalité telle qu'elle est et aider
ses pays à s'en sortir je crois que
c'est aussi simple que ça pour pour les
Kurdes la une des routes privilégiées en
fait c'est justement de passer par la
Turquie parce que c'est très facile en
fait pour eux de d'obtenir un visa donc
c'est une des on va dire des voix les
plus empruntées en fait pour pour
rejoindre l'Europe mais il y en a
beaucoup qui échouent la frontière voir
aux perles de leur vie parfois un
dernier mot et un dernier mot c'est vrai
que c'est un c'est quelque chose aussi
que j'ai j'ai pas traité profondément le
reportage on n'a pas le temps de tout
dire mais le cœur distant rêve de son
indépendance aussi et ça c'est quelque
chose dont on entend parler absolument
partout parce qu'en 2017 il y a eu un
référendum à ce sujet il y a eu 93% à
l'époque de oui ce référendum mais qui
n'a jamais été suivi des faits parce que
ça ça a été tellement contesté par la
tutelle de Bagdad qui a vu une sécession
de ce territoire et des pays aux
alentours l'Iran la Turquie qui voyait
en fait un une déstabilisation très très
grande de leur de voilà de leur diaspora
de leur territoire ils ont des
diasporacures de très très fort et à
l'époque aussi la communauté
internationale avait farouchement
fait savoir son opposition le problème
c'est qu'en fait il y a pas il y en a 5
et vous avez des communautés kurdes en
Turquie en Iran en Syrie en Irak et même
bien ailleurs et si vous voulez c'est le
résultat de ces découpages insensés qui
sont intervenus après la guerre de 14
dans les fameux traités et donc ce
peuple qui a qui ne se confond en rien
avec ses voisins et disperser en plus
n'est pas toujours ils ne sont pas
toujours d'accord les uns entre eux les
uns avec les autres et donc c'est vrai
que c'est un une région que nous devons
regarder de près car elle peut de
nouveau exploser mais elle peut aussi
connaître un avenir plus favorable c'est
en tous les cas ce que j'espère et
c'était le sens de cette mission on va
redire merci Jonathan merci pour votre
reportage et c'est avoir demain sur
notre antenne Kurdistan territoire à
l'épreuve demain 18h sur notre antenne
du coup rester avec nous Jonathan il
nous reste un petit peu de temps
Christian Cambon un mot puisque Emmanuel
Macron sera à Toulon mercredi vous
l'accompagnerez je crois pour présenter
les grandes lignes de la future loi de
programmation militaire qu'est-ce que
vous en attendez doivent être les
priorités les priorités ça doit être la
continuité par rapport à la première loi
de programmation dont je dois dire ici
avec honnêteté qu'elle a été respectée
c'est à dire qu'effectivement on va
finir cette loi avec 295 milliards ce
qui paraît une somme énorme mais par
rapport à l'iraintement dont les forces
françaises ont fait l'objet pendant 20
ans c'est un effort qui a été fait mais
ceci n'aurait aucun sens s'il n'y avait
pas une suite ça c'est un premier point
et donc nous attendons que le même
effort soit poursuivi mais ce qu'il
convient de faire c'est aussi maintenant
de tirer les enseignements depuis la
dernière loi de programmation de deux ou
trois événements très importants d'une
part nos déboires au Sahel il y a quand
même des conséquences à en tirer et
deuxièmement l'affrontement entre la
Russie et l'Ukraine la guerre en Europe
qui est en train de changer ton
logiciels en termes d'armement en termes
de munitions je l'ai dit ici à plusieurs
reprises en termes de défense aérienne
je reparlerai de ces sujets qui sont
aussi assez inquiétants pour la France
en termes de coopération européenne face
à tout cela on parle de de l'attitude de
l'Allemagne comment ces choses peuvent
se régler et donc je notre armée elle
est pas prête à faire la guerre et
est-ce qu'elle a été affaiblie par les
livraisons d'armes en Ukraine elle a été
affaibli effectivement si demain on
était si demain on devait entrer en
conflit évidemment les armes qu'on a
donné on les a plus ceci posé je crois
qu'il faut maintenant qu'il y ait un
travail avec les industriels puisque
jusqu'à présent c'était une industrie de
défense un industrie du temps de paix
bon alors brusquement si vous commandez
20 missiles par an à un industriel vous
pouvez pas lui dire tiens ben le mois
prochain il faudrait en livrer 100 parce
que lui il a combiné son son affaire sur
la quantité que l'État lui achète
Emmanuel Macron la semaine dernière il
était avant il a demandé au sein
industriel de produire plus et produire
plus vite bon ça c'est possible de
passer de la parole aux actes rapidement
bah écoutez pour l'instant un canon
César qui est notre arme d'élite si
j'ose dire en matière de en matière de
bombarde
[Musique]